[Musique]
le jour est à peine levé sur la campagne
languedocienne mais germaine la
poissonnière comme chaque matin est déjà
sur son vélomoteur pour gagner l'un des
marchés de la région times ce matin elle
a quitté son village du grau d'agde pour
aller à 20 km de là sur le marché de
mont blanc
[Musique]
j'aime être ça un gars qui pleuvent qui
perdra commentaire sur ce moteur du
parti
j'ai dû choisir et tout à volonté tout
le monde qu'elle est que ce jour nous
avons droit leurs drones et 3 750 et à
quelle heure vous êtes levé ce matin
moi je me lève en tout quatre et cinq
heures deux fois troisième train moi je
ne regarde au quotidien et parce que je
respire le bon enneigement tél je
respire un air de la marque mais disons
que ça fait les rouges et alors vous
avez déjà c'est toi c'est moi je ne
traite pas rare je prépare en tout et je
fais un bon café je me rends café qu'est
ce que tu as tout un réseau de faire
vibrer sous peine de devoir fuir alors
nous avons eu 15 fr bon enfant les
titres à marennes vous avez pas laissé
grand monsieur l'apéritif des raisons
liées et pourquoi vous n'avez pas de
voiture
c'est trop moderne tout ça crie ça fait
la pollution
parce qu'en voiture vous savez ça marche
dit on n'a rien du tout on peut pas
profiter
et puis c'est bon vous savez oui flano
gauyacq sens aux tomates s'est pas borné
et comme ça m'a mis une famille un kilo
mon amour sous ma clientèle
j'ai pas de mari alors j'ai mis tout mon
amour ça c'est mes trois fils et puis
mes clients voilà quel travail vous
n'arrêtez pas blâmer c'est toujours
contre ça mais j'avais tiré mais je me
tourne le moment je prenais ça chante
aussi bel et bien à 12 suit la dalle
poissonnière je suis belle et pas cher
c'est vrai je suis nature et sa manière
les ateliers s'y plaire c'est vrai j'ai
dit à jean delabroy de la rascasse du
bon maire la radio capella et sur la
place à ce jeu suit celle que l'on peut
le faire avec le poissonnière c'est vrai
[Musique]
ici à volkan meilleurs moments de la
journée pour vous ouais ouais tout
désert semblaient il n'a pas eu une plus
belle que les à chacun son charme
parce que tu m'as déjà le poisson
l'après midi sache que je fais je moi je
l'achetais que la maison je veux mais
notre tenue j'ai pu l'apprécier à 3
heures de l'après-midi sacha fait sans
tourner le disque à tourner je suis plus
la poissonnière
je suis la danse
[Musique]
[Rires]